At an elementary school, there are a lot of students for which Spanish is their
first language. Now let's say there are two ways of teaching English to them.
One way is to only teach them in English. Another way is to teach them in both
English and Spanish. So researchers randomly assigned students to one of these
two groups. One student were assigned to either being taught in English only or
in both Spanish and English, it stayed that way. After a while, the researchers
gave each student a reading comprehension test. On the day of testing for the
English only group, the temperature was 72 degrees Fahrenheit. But for the
bilingual group the temperature was 100 degrees Fahrenheit, which is pretty hot.
When the scores were calculated, the English only group had an average of 70%,
while the bilingual group had an average of 55%.